[Music]
it's the height of the gold rush 1850s
California a young tailor named Jacob
Davis notices that his gold-mining
customers are wearing through pants
faster than they can patch them in a
moment of vision
Davis adds reinforcing metal rivets to
his pant design strategically placing
them at points of strain like the
corners of pockets and the base of the
fly the Enhanced trousers are soon in
high demand in order to take out a
patent on the highly successful riveted
pant Davis means a business partner he
approaches the supplier of his cloth a
dry-goods merchant by the name of Levi
Strauss Strauss and Davis begin
manufacturing pants out of denim and
continue to modify the design to
accommodate their customers it is
rumored that the removal of the crotch
rivet was due to a complaint from the
miners that squatting too near a
campfire in their typical underwear free
fashion could be painful jeans continued
to be modified and diversified over the
years eventually becoming an everyday
fashion item for both work and play by
the 1960s
today 96% of American consumers own at
least one if not many pairs of jeans
[Music]
you